und in diesem moment kommt der perfekten
übergabe bundespräsident steinmeier um
zu sprechen das herz schwer in diesen
tagen
russlands präsident hat unter
irischen vorwänden einen angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine entfesselt
es ist furchtbar was die menschen dort
jetzt durchleben müssen
tod und verwundung
zerstörung
vertreibung
vieltausendfache slide ganz in unserer
nähe
die nachbarn unserer nachbarn
präsident putin
vergisst es blut jenes volkes
dass er eben noch bruder volk nannte
ich appelliere an präsident putin
stoppen sie den wahnsinn dieses krieges
jetzt
wir sind mit unseren gefühlen und
gedanken bei den menschen in der ukraine
die opfer dieses krieges sind
auch für die menschen in russland wird
das handeln ihres präsidenten bittere
folgen haben ich sage ihnen allen wir
wollen keine feindschaft mit dem
russischen volk im gegenteil aber dieses
unrecht kann nicht ohne deutliche
antwort bleiben
dafür arbeitet die bundesregierung
entschlossen und gemeinsam mit unseren
partnern im nordatlantischen bündnis und
der europäischen union darauf können sie
vertrauen und
deutschland wird seinen teil dazu
beitragen um putin von gewalt gegen
unsere partner im bündnis
abzuschrecken und abzuhalten
uns deutschen wird dass manches
abverlangen ja das ist eine zäsur für
tiefe zäsur und wir spüren dass
bis ins mark sie ihre familien
und auch ich selbst
aber ich habe es vor diesem angriff
gesagt und ich sage es noch einmal
der russische präsident sollte die
stärke der demokratien nicht
unterschätzen und
bitte liebe landsleute
unterschätzen wir nicht die stärke
unserer demokratie
es ist gut dass die menschen
auf die straßen und plätze in unserem
land gehen und genau das zum ausdruck
bringen zeigen wir den menschen in der
ukraine
unsere anteilnahme und solidarität
der russische präsident
soll nicht eine sekunde lang glauben
dass die menschen in deutschland europa
diese brutale gewalt einfach hinnehmen
und zeigen wir auch den menschen in
russland die frieden wollen
dass sie nicht alleine dastehen zeigen
wir einander und unseren partnern gerade
jetzt was uns wichtig ist wir wollen
frieden wir wollen freiheit recht und
selbstbestimmung für die völker europas
vielen dank